[Musique]
niché au bord de la manche sans veilleux
avec plus de 40000 habitants une ville à
taille humaine une cité balnéaire un
coeur historique mais en centre ville
des rideaux baissés des vitrines vides
c'est la désertification les commerces
ferment les uns après les autres
2 116 boutiques affichent portes closes
soit plus de 30% des magasins autre
ambiance à quelques kilomètres de là des
voitures des parkings plein des services
des familles cinq zones commerciales en
périphérie de saint brieuc s'étendent et
s'étale et font de l'ombre au centre
ville
bonjour j'aurais besoin de deux trois
trucs saudrais dés les tomates
ouais super bruno est un résistant il
habite dans le centre ville de saint
brieuc depuis 25 ans et il fait ses
courses du quotidien
malgré sa bonne volonté lui aussi fait
les frais des fermetures de magasins en
2017 27 commerce ont mis la clé sous la
porte
à saint brieuc dont ce magasin où il
avait ses petites habitudes deux minutes
du centre-ville je n'ai acheté mais
surgelés aujourd'hui plus de magasins de
surgelés
j'ai appris que ce magasin avait décidé
d'une troisième implantation en banlieue
[Musique]
la zone périphérique ou désormais il
envisage à contrecoeur d'aller acheter
ses surgelés
il vient déjà y faire quelques courses
ses produits ménagers et déposer son
linge au pressing
bruno est aussi obligé d'aller sur
internet pour acheter les produits de
consommation qui ne trouvent pas dans le
centre de saint brieuc je suis en train
de commander mon café
tout le monde est un peu noir à saint
mayeux tout le monde critique le centre
ville les commerces qui meurent machin
qui se tramait en attendant pour les
mères de famille douze litres d'eau à
portée on comprend que en centre-ville
c'est pas très pratique parce qu'on peut
pas forcément se garer en bas de chez
soi après 20 voyez bien les
propriétaires de magasins il faut eux
aussi qu'ils apportent leur pierre à
l'édifice c'est à dire qu'il soit
susceptible de faire sans doute des
loyers un peu moins élevé pour permettre
à d'autres commerces de s'installer
nécessairement la ville qu'est les élus
ont un rôle particulièrement important à
jouer
saint brieuc a tous les symptômes d'un
mal qui touche près de 600 villes et
bourgs en france en moyenne 10% des
centres ville sont désertées dans
l'hexagone grignotée par des centres
commerciaux en périphérie mais aussi par
les ventes en ligne qui représente
aujourd'hui 7% du commerce
parmi les villes les plus touchées par
ce mal français
châtellerault dans la vienne ici lé
sénateur martial bourquin et rémy
pointereau sont venus rencontrer les
représentants des commerces de la ville
les deux sénateurs sont les rapporteur
d'une mission sénatoriale mise en place
en mai 2017 dont l'objectif est de créer
des outils pour revitaliser les centre
villes ils comptent nourrir grâce à
l'expérience de ces acteurs de terrain
la proposition de loi qu'ils rendront au
terme de leurs travaux
[Musique]
regarder ensemble toutes les actions que
j'ai menées et les propositions qu'on
pourrait faire notre travers d'autres
notre rapport est notre proposition de
loi pour faire avancer les choses c'est
urgent de trouver les solutions très
rapidement avant que mal de soi trop pas
pourquoi il faut que nous débouchons sur
un projet de loi qui met en place un un
plan d'action pour sauver nos centres
viennent au centre-bourg
il faut un projet global et il faut que
nous arrivions à inverser les flux faire
en sorte que plus tôt qu'ils aillent
vers la périphérie
on ramène des flux de logements on
ramène des flux de service
on ramène des flux commerciaux vers les
quarts david hâlé centre-bourg premier
objectif des sénateurs arrêté
l'extension des centres commerciaux à
perpignan c'est la surdose cette ville
de 100000 habitants est encerclée par
six zones commerciales l'équivalent de
85 terrain de rugby
en 15 ans la ville catalane est devenue
championne de france des mètres carrés
commerciaux en périphérie
les élus ont laissé faire et ici ce sont
des initiatives citoyennes qui stoppe la
frénésie des constructions clotilde
ripoull présidente de l'association
perpignan équilibre se bat pour que ce
bâtiment convoité par un promoteur
immobilier ne soit pas transformé en
centre commercial en classe et l'ancien
bâtiment
de meubles de george à henri quinta
comme c'est écrit là par l'intérieur et
ce bâtiment qui a été promis à la
destruction complète pour être remplacés
ces 1500 mètres carrés pour être
remplacé par un gros bol de 8500 mètres
carrés à deux reprises son association a
déposé des recours auprès de l'organisme
qui autorise les ouvertures extensions
de centres commerciaux
la commission départementale
d'aménagement commercial la cdac et pour
la deuxième fois elle a gagné ce jour là
elle vient annoncer la bonne nouvelle
aux autres membres de l'association un
petit bilan sur le projet comptera donc
j'ai reçu il ya quelques jours le
quel avis la commission nationale
d'aménagement commercial il émettre un
avis défavorable qui sur huit votes
il ya eu sept défavorable et une
abstention donc c'est vrai on a bien
gagné puis il n'y a eu aucun vote un
vote favorable on s'est interrogé pour
savoir comment lutter par rapport à ces
grandes surfaces
mais c'est vrai que c'est assez obscur
et c'est pas du tout transfèrement la
façon dont ça fonctionne c'est cdac donc
en tant qu association citoyenne on a
été présenté ce que l'on reprochait
devant tous les membres de la cdac qui
étaient présents
déjà ça a changé vraiment beaucoup leur
façon de voir parce qu'ils se sont
sentis observé ce avec leurs votes
seraient pris en considération et ça a
été notre première victoire s'est fait
dire les élus ont une part de
responsabilité dans l'augmentation des
surfaces commerciales en périphérie pour
la bonne raison c'est que le fait qu'on
diminue les dotations dans les
collectivités comme il ya moins de
recettes de la part de l'état les élus
essaient de compenser la diminution des
recettes de l'état par des recettes sur
des emprises foncières qui vont ou
vendus ou loués dans le cadre de leurs
travaux
les sénateurs vont auditionner les élus
locaux à plusieurs reprises ils ont
exprimé l'idée de revoir le
fonctionnement des cdac comme patrick
ollier président de la métropole du
grand paris les commissions
départementales et cédé à séoul et ses
lacets anas et c'est pas bon ça
fonctionne pas comme il faudrait que ça
fonctionne parce que ce sont bien
souvent des arrangements
il faut arrêter tout ça il faut je dis
pas qu'il ya des mauvaises volontés qui
s'organisait doigt c'est pas ça mais
c'est logique de rapport de force qui
joue toujours contre celui qui est le
moins fort
il faut que la loi permette de faire en
sorte que ce soit des rapports justes
[Musique]
beaucoup
retour dans le centre ville de perpignan
même si petit de ripoull a gagné une
bataille
la guerre contre les zones commerciales
n'est pas terminée un nouveau projet de
grandes surfaces en périphérie va être
présenté en cdac
elle mobilise les commerçants sur contrô
leurs corps qu'on a fait qu'aboutit donc
maintenant on attend de voir si l'on
relance et se loger ou femme m'a proposé
maintes fois de quitter le centre ville
pour aller à l'extérieur
jamais je n'ai voulu parce que je crois
en la cité je crois l'agora je crois au
centre-ville
je crois et je crois comme simone d'un
département d'une région
c'est aussi la ville c'est l'avis d'un
ami je pense que la place de notre
librairie doit être en ville donc ici
c'était une petite surface d'une
enseigne de proximité donc été remplacé
par un visuel qui donne l'impression
qu'il ya un commerce alors qu'il y en a
plus mais c'est assez symptomatique des
problèmes de cette rue donc à partir du
moment où on passe
son temps à augmenter ce qu'il ya en
périphérie c'est vrai qu'on détourne les
gens de ce type de points de vente ont
mené une campagne active de
revitalisation il faut déjà commencer
par faire un moratoire sur les surfaces
extérieures de façon à éviter cette
double concurrence
l'idée c'est de se dire on on se pose
alors moi je ne suis pas pour un
moratoire national parce qu'il ya des
des territoires ou peut-être que oui il
n'y a pas de difficultés majeures de
positionnement des grandes surfaces en
périphérie mais je pense qu'à un moment
donné il faut se poser la question
savoir s'il n'y a pas suffisamment de de
commerce dans une catégorie donnée sur
un territoire donné sans que ça agissent
contre l'intérêt de nos centres vider
nos centres mourrait pour rééquilibrer
les flux commerciaux
les sénateurs souhaitent également
inciter les commerçants à revenir en
centre-ville
[Musique]
on va aller visiter le local à alençon
boris play propriétaire d'une
boulangerie en périphérie souhaite
ouvrir une seconde enseigne en centre
ville mais les conditions d'installation
ne sont pas toujours facile après ça
avoir faucheuse dire d'agenceur pourvoir
prouve exactement ça nous coûterait
d'abord aménager sa en boulangerie parce
que là du coup je voulais très las le le
comptoir derrière le pain c'est
principalement coup et je vous dis
réticences des des propriétaires qui
veulent pas je j'ignore pourquoi mais
ils veulent pas d'alimentaire en fait
dans leurs locaux veulent pas de
transformation alimentaire et préfère
avoir des locaux vides donc je me suis
heurté à beaucoup beaucoup de fois ça et
le reste du temps c'était des loyers
exorbitants parce que en boulangerie
faut énormément de place et
malheureusement du coup le prix va avec
et voilà qu'en périphérie marrer tous
les prix sont beaucoup plus abordables
sabots locale
les charges sont plus fortes en centre
ville qu'en périphérie
donc je pense qu'il faut qu'on essaie de
faire une ce qu'on pourrait appeler une
discrimination fiscale qui soit plutôt
meilleur pour les centre-villes est plus
forte pour les la périphérie pour qu'on
ait un équilibre rééquilibre de coût
entre les deux installations de sauter
ça se sent levée de façon à gagner au
niveau de l'espace du local sous les
maîtres des petites tables de bourj abou
toulouse ça peut sauter en espace
celle qui a mis en relation le
propriétaire et le boulanger c'est
mathilde traitons lé manager de commerce
elle a été embauchée par la ville
d'alençon il y a trois ans ce jour-là
elle joue le rôle d'agent immobilier
mais elle a bien d'autres cordes à son
arc on essaie de mettre en place une
certaine aussi
dynamique par de l'animation commerciale
que ce soit des chèques cadeaux
l'animation sur les réseaux sociaux de
l'animation dans les rues tout ça peut
contribuer justement à un retour des
commerces en centre-ville sa toute
dernière opération faire intervenir des
experts auprès des commerçants comme
dans cette boutique de jouets ou la
propriétaire avait besoin de conseils
d'agencement mathilde a fait appel à une
décoratrice d'intérieur peut-être se
mettre un peu plus en avant en faire un
peu plus de failles ici qu'on voit un
petit peu les produits du coup même
peut-être les espaces et vu qu'on a
plusieurs coloris
voilà les mettre plus en avant on a plus
l'intérêt de voir le produit que la
petite patte rc c'est bien c'est un
c'est un vraiment un rôle de
coordinateur qui est très important je
pense qu'une association de commerçants
fonctions le métier de manager de
commerce n'est pas nouveau il est apparu
dans les années 90
aujourd'hui ils sont près de 400 en
france est de plus en plus de
collectivités font appel à ces acteurs
pour dynamiser et animer le commerce en
centre ville
les sénateurs aimeraient faciliter
l'embauché de ces acteurs par les
collectivités
on a dans beaucoup de villes des unions
commerciales qui s'entendent pas
toujours bien entre elle et qui
finalement ne font pas l'animation qui
permet d'être actif pour les la
clientèle et la joie il ya vraiment une
nécessité de former nos commerçants sur
l'animation de mettre en place des
manager de centre-ville qui fédère
l'ensemble des unions commerciales qui
fait dans les commerces à former les
commerçants à l'animation mais aussi à
la vente sur internet
les sénateurs souhaitent accompagner les
commerçants à l'évolution des modes de
consommation comme dans cette boutique
de chaussures à saint brieuc c'est
vraiment nude après on n'est plus sûr du
belge qui est sympa également un peu
nacré yves henry voile ans a ouvert son
magasin il ya 35 ans mais depuis
quelques années la concurrence
d'internet
aspyr 10% de ses ventes et a fait
baisser son chiffre d'affaires poussé
par adeline une de ses employées il a
franchi le pas et créé un site de vente
en ligne
aujourd'hui c'est elle qui le gère
qu'est ce qu'on a vu hier une vain hélas
les photos à faire des photos à faire
adeline travail à 80% sur le web et le
reste du temps elles vont en magasin ont
quasiment une vente tous les jours vous
voir plusieurs par jour là il serait que
lors des black friday et des sols
là c'était jusqu'à 5 6 par jour donc ça
et que c'était beaucoup d'un coup et
c'est bien là on voit une évolution
kalman ans quand même au moins une vente
les jours c'était pas du tout mon
éducation j'ai pas j'ai pas pris ça veut
pas je connaissais rien et donc il
reconnaît que de fait d'avoir une
employée jeunes qui est de l'âge
d'internet
elle nous a un peu boosté quoi on en
parlait il faut qu'on y aille parce que
mon force de voir les gens dans les
boutiques essayé après ben si il y à pas
la pointure moi je vais aller sur
internet
donc une fois deux fois puis les tous
les jours ça commence à être un peu
lassant dont kenza dc6 ici et puis bon
on s'y est mis
après six mois et près de 20000 euros
investis il fait encore peu de ventes
mais le site lui apporte une toute
nouvelle visibilité une vitrine digital
[Musique]
c'est la chambre de commerce et
d'industrie qui a formé et accompagné le
commerçant pour son projet ce jour là
ils font de coin
ça serait bien aussi de sortir après
d'une logique d'avoir une nouvelle
clientèle aussi grâce au site web bien
un investissement qui a été fait pour
aussi essayer d'attirer des gens qui
vous connaissent peut-être pas forcément
par idylle même si c'est connu sur saint
brieuc des gens qui connaissent pas
forcément encore l'enseigne france
bouriane il sait pas que durait même les
gens de l'as du secteur de saint brieuc
qui vous connaissent pas forcément en
tant qu'enseigne mais qui pourrait
rechercher vos produits par marque donc
là il faut que l'outil fin tout est prêt
après ça sera un choix d'entreprise d'y
aller ou pas on l'était soit logique de
dire que le web allait aller tuer les
commerces de centre-ville ce n'est pas
le cas c'est pas le cas je pense qu'il
ya un vrai plaisir à aller faire du
shopping en centre ville mais les
commerçants qui ont réussi c'est les
commerçants comme monsieur el amri
volante qui ont gardé un point de vente
on a vu le point de vente midi le saint
point de vente on a plaisir à aller donc
les commerces qui réussissent à sortir
leur épingle du jeu c'est des commerces
qui ont un vrai une vraie expérience
shopping en magasin et qui se servent du
web pour pour promouvoir en fait ce
savoir faire et des larmes mon avis la
clé de la réussite c'est une changement
qui va arriver
allez dans les trois à quatre ans qui
viennent si le train n'est pas pris du
e-commerce
on peut aller vers une situation
irréversible
d'abord il ya beaucoup de centre ville
et de centres bourgs qui n'ont pas le
très haut débit
il faut que tous les centres villes les
choeurs de coeur de l'agglomération les
centre-bourgs soient équipés en réseau
consommer en ligne est devenu une
habitude en 2017
37 millions de français ont dépensé 82
millions d'euros sur internet un marché
phagocyter en partie par les gaffes à
google apple facebook et surtout amazon
meilleurs sites de vente en ligne avec
46% des ventes françaises des gaffes à
qui déstabilisent de plus en plus les
grandes enseignes
lors de leur audition au sénat elles
font part de leur inquiétude
le prince qui se posent en matière de
fiscalité c'est qu amazon pour prendre
cet exemple il bénéficie d'un double
avantage
premier avantage qui est un avantage de
modèles c'est que par définition il n'a
pas de magasin
donc ils payent pas d'impôts fonciers
sauf sur quelques entrepôts par ci par
là
c'est un sujet qui est tout à fait
majeur de ce point de vue ça commerçants
du centre ville et donc il a des coups
en moins qui sont inhérents à ce modèle
et puis deuxième élément c'est que comme
vous le savez amazon com google est
haute comme l'ensemble des gaffes et
d'autres n'existent pas fiscalement en
france et donc il faut absolument que
face à ça il y a une politique publique
qui soit une politique d'égalité des
conditions de concurrence
s'il n'y a pas égalité des conditions de
concurrence tout ce qui pourra être fait
par ailleurs ne servit à rien et donc ça
pour nous c'est quelque chose qui est
totalement majeur mais centre ville se
plaignent de la périphérie trop
importante et du e-commerce et les
commerces de périphérie se plaignent de
la concurrence déloyale du e-commerce
donc il faut entre tout cela et trouver
le bon équilibre
il faut qu'on invente une une fiscalité
adaptée qui se fera certainement avec au
niveau européen mais soit seul chiffre
d'affaires soit sur les volumes de de
livraison qui vont être
fait sur chacun des départements
[Musique]
internet et grandes surfaces ne sont pas
les seuls responsables de la
dévitalisation lors des auditions les
sénateurs écoute aussi les témoignages
d'élus locaux
nicolas sort et président de la
communauté commune de joigny dans
l'yonne explique comment le centre ville
de joigny a été dévitalisées suite aux
réformes successives de l'état on a
perdu 10% de la population carrément en
trois mois
avec la fermeture d'un site militaire on
a perdu le tribunal d'instance la même
année le tribunal de commerce la même
année la chirurgie la même année la
maternité la même année la moitié de
tout ça était enfin et deux tirs le tout
ça était en centre ville au moment où
l'état se désengage edge ouaninou cédant
à l'euro symbolique merci du cadeau 14
hectares 40 bâtiments des militaires à
ce moment-là pôle emploi chercher des
locaux qui sont aller louer en zone
d'activité dans le privé dix fois j'ai
dit au préfet mais vous n'allez pas
laisser faire ça on sait plus quoi faire
de notre bâti n'allez quand même pas
envoyé pour l'emploi en zone d'activités
mais si monsieur le président parce que
là-bas ya des parkings
voilà donc cqfd si même la puissance
publique ne nous aide pas voilà nous
retrouverons nicolas saurait avec le
maire de joigny bernard moraine sur ce
site
les militaires fabriquer des cartes 10
hectares en coeur de ville où eelv et
400 familles qui est injecté 700 mille
euros dans l'économie locale
en 2010 ils ont quitté les lieux un coup
de massue pour les élus
on a perdu des contribuables on a perdu
des enfants pour nos écoles on a perdu
des clients pour nos commerces
extérieurs ha l'état indemnise la ville
à hauteur de 3 millions d'euros
insuffisant pour le maire qui se bat
pour faire revivre le lieu peu à peu se
créer un pôle social un centre de
formation une salle de sport et il ya
six mois à la grande fierté du maire un
cinéma gaumont champs maxime ici à
joigny soit vous faisiez 25 km dans un
sens pour aller à auxerre soit 25 km
dans l'autre sens pour aller à sens mais
bref n'y avait pas de véritable offre
cinématographique à joigny donc ça y est
c'est fait la fermeture des équipements
culturels la fermeture des commerces de
proximité la fermeture des services
publics
eh bien on peut tenter d'y mettre un
stop un arrêt et il faut une volonté
politique cette volonté politique on l'a
eu et on est on est juste récompensé par
le public qui fréquentent ces lieux là
et ça c'est un grand bonheur pour un élu
pour des élus effectivement ça marche on
six mois le cinéma agnès varda a fait
dix mille entrées
[Musique]
autre conséquence après le départ des
militaires
jouanny s'est vidée de sa population
dans le centre historique nombre de
logements sont vacants et se dégrade
avec le temps le maire qui cherche des
solutions pour réhabiliter l'habitat de
cette cité médiévale a trouvé une idée
en périphérie dans le quartier de la
madeleine
[Musique]
c'est ce bâtiment qui va être démoli
donc il y en a une partie qui sera
reconstruite ici à peu près la moitié
entre 20 et 25
et puis l'autre partie qui sera donc
reconstruire ou réhabiliter en centre
ancien c'est un peu cette idée que nous
avons grâce à l' agence nationale de
rénovation urbaine l'anru
un programme qui réhabilite des zones
urbaines sensibles
il a proposé qu au lieu de reconstruire
ici 50 logements neufs
le programme non bâti ce que 25 en
échange 25 autres seront réhabilités
dans le centre historique
mais là tout est plus compliqué donc là
on arrive devant un immeuble
un beau matin ça c'est une partie de la
façade s'est effondrée
voilà on a contacté la propriétaire donc
l'idée c'est que n où le vent et nous on
leur tape et on le met on leur met la
location et à terme la ville se
retrouvera par le paiement des loyers et
se retrouvera aussi en réinvestissant le
centre ancien quand vous construisez du
neuf
disons c'est 100 quand vous réhabiliter
des maisons à pans de bois en
particulier ses 300 voilà donc la
puissance publique doit nous aider on
essaie de tirer tous les crédits
possibles faire aligner les lignes de
crédit possible pour réaliser ce projet
est allé ville patrimoniale ou c'est
très compliqué parce que c'est
l'architecte des bâtiments de france
rassure tous les projets et c'est très
coûteux faut se pencher sur ces villes
patrimoniales pour qu'on fasse baisser
les coûts pour que c'est aussi réfléchir
aux normes pas tout un mais certaines
normes
est ce que on n'a pas une attitude
vis-à-vis du du bâti historique quelque
chose qui soit plus qu il une approche
beaucoup plus souple
parfois il ya deux trois maisons qui
sont délabrés faut peut-être les raser
puis m 2 les beaux logements à côté
c'est ce que j'ai fait moins dans la
ville et on peut on peut faire gagner je
suis pas dans certaines villes
un millier d'habitants centre-ville
[Musique]
revoir les normes pour faciliter la
rénovation de l'habitat créer des outils
pour moderniser le commerce ou encore
rectifier les règles d'installation
commercial les initiatives des élus de
joigny des associations de perpignan ou
encore des commerçants de saint brieuc
sont autant d'exemples qui seront
formalisées dans la proposition de loi
des sénateurs
le gouvernement aussi à ses plans pour
la revitalisation en décembre 2017
jacques mézard ministre de la cohésion
des territoires a présenté un plan coeur
de ville 5 milliard d'euros pour
dynamiser plusieurs dizaines de villes
moyennes choisis sur dossier
ce projet doit être formalisée dans une
loi la loi est lent porté par la
secrétaire d'état delfina génie stéphane
ce jour-là elle souhaite rencontrer les
sénateurs avec un objectif trouver des
synergies entre leurs travaux et le
projet de loi du gouvernement mais un
concept de revitalisation locale
contracte contractualiser sur un certain
de centre bourg et qui en qui qui inclut
à la fois les sujets commerciaux mais
aussi le sujet
d'action foncière logement enfin qui va
au delà du seul les auditions c'est un
sujet qu'on a au québec comme ailleurs
la conférence de l'absence hausse
conforme en effet si vous avez de bons
c'est diversement appréciée vous aurez
inévitablement des bourgs qui seront
choisies et d'autres pas choisir et ça
peut aussi attirer une concurrence on
travaillerait plus tôt avec rémy sur une
des mesures globales qui qui ont éveillé
l'ensemble du territoire
on parle de prendre une vingtaine de
deux villes par an pour essayer de faire
des actions concrètes alors que les
besoins aujourd'hui c'est 600 villes qui
sont en difficulté 600 villes qui ont
des problèmes de dévitalisation de
centre-ville
alors moi je dis simplement c'est pas un
plan mézard qui nous font peur mais ça
il faut qu'il se transforme en plan
marshall vraiment un plan marshall qui
soit vraiment volontariste pour aller
plus vite et plus fort dans la
revitalisation du centre-ville
[Musique]
un plan marshall ont stoppé l'hémorragie
et injecter du sang neuf afin que le
coeur de nos villes françaises bat de
nouveau rythme de leurs habitants et de
leur commerce
[Musique]